Speaker 1: Well, my friends, today is such an
important show that I actually got a haircut for
today's show. The right wing is now attacking John
Fetterman for his stroke. And yet they continue
to say absolutely nothing about Herschel Walker's
complete inability to think or speak or coherently
explain his views on even a single issue, making
it very obvious that this isn't really about
John Fetterman, his condition. So let's back up
and kind of reset the stage. In Pennsylvania,
there's a very important Senate race. The
Republican nominee is television. Dr. Mehmet Oz,
the Democratic nominee is the lieutenant governor,
John Fetterman. John Fetterman had a stroke some
months ago, and as part of his recovery, he
is having auditory processing issues. And
as a result, we learned recently during an
NBC interview that when he is interviewed,
he uses closed captioning, meaning that there
is a voice to text mechanism which shows him
on a screen what he is being asked to kind of
contextualize that. Here's a report explaining it
and an interview he gave using that technology.
Speaker 2: Another pivotal Senate race in
Pennsylvania now considered a toss up. Our Dasha
Burns spoke with Democrat John Fetterman in his
first in-person sit down interview since he
suffered a stroke. And Dasha, this was not a
typical candidate interview. No, Lester because of
his stroke, veteran's campaign required a closed
captioning technology for this interview to
essentially read our questions as we ask them
and Lester small talk before the interview
without captioning it wasn't clear he was
understanding our conversation. Can voters trust
that you will be able to do this job on day one?
Yeah, of course. This is Pennsylvania
Democratic Senate candidate John Fetterman,
first in-person sit down interview since a stroke
sidelined him from the campaign trail for months.
That auditory processing where I'll hear someone
speaking but sometimes will be able to be precise
on what exactly that they're saying. I use
captioning his campaign require that he be
allowed to use a transcription program on his
computer. During our interview, I always thought
I was pretty empathetic. Emphatic. I think
I was very excuse me, empathetic. You know,
that's an example of the stroke. Empathetic.
Speaker 1: All right. So you get the picture. Now,
I am not going to pretend for a second
that this is a non issue. What we are told
by doctors is that this is not a cognitive
issue of Fetterman understanding concepts,
but that it is an auditory processing issue which
often takes time to get back to normal for someone
who has suffered a stroke. In other words, it's
turning the audio into meaningful messages in his
brain. Now the right, many on the right are saying
he should just withdraw immediately and in fact,
as if this is going to be a fair conversation.
Fox Business host Maria BARTIROMO had veterans
opponent Mehmet Oz on, and she said the following.
Speaker 2: Well, it's also very questionable to
understand the need for this computer to
be with me. I mean, how is she going to
make decisions about Pennsylvania and fight
for the Pennsylvanian people if, in fact,
she needs to have a device alongside him? So is
this just all the time you need such a bias or is.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way? Maria BARTIROMO can't
even do a TV show without a teleprompter and an
earpiece where producers can talk to her. So
it's it's kind of a weird direction to go.
Speaker 2: Just during an
interview, I don't understand.
No one knows. We've not been actually exposed to
this before. It's the first in-person interview.
Here we are less than a month before the election,
and I've been asking John Fetterman to answer
questions on the campaign trail. Initially,
he wasn't even on the campaign trail for the
first couple of months. But answer questions
from voters, answer questions from reporters
while you're actually campaigning. That's what
we normally do in a democracy. And the concern,
of course, is that if you don't ever leave
your home and ask your questions, we don't
know the answers to the questions you're asking.
Speaker 1: All right. So this is the this is the
approach that they're going with here. The reality
is that while we can be concerned about Fetterman,
his recovery as is so dangerous and so unqualified
and so pathetic, that, of course, Pennsylvania
voters should still vote for John Fetterman,
if indeed what we are being told by doctors
about Fetterman is condition is wrong or his
recovery goes in a different way than predicted.
I'm thinking ahead many steps, but he could
resign and hopefully then Democratic Governor Josh
SHAPIRO can select the replacement until the next
election, as he has no business even being in this
race. And so there is really no choice to be made
here. Now, here's John Fetterman take on all this.
Speaker 3: Will you be releasing updated
information from your doctor on your health
before November eight?
Speaker 2:
I would say that if there was anything that they
changed or whatever, I absolutely would have
updated that. You know, other than the progress
that I've made, it's evident. No, I certainly not
are going to be able to sit in front of you back
in May or in June or July, because they recovered
the kind of recovery that I need in order to be
absolutely whatever getting better and better.
And I think the ultimate kinds of transparency is
to be in front of thousands of people on a stage,
not using a teleprompter. Most often kinds of
politicians use a teleprompter, but nobody wonders
if he or she is able to do the job or anything
like that. It's simply about that. That's how
that's the kind of campaign that I've run on.
Speaker 1: So, listen, we can all be honest and
recognize that that this is not the same John
Fetterman right now from before the stroke.
We can also understand that there's not really a
choice here where, oh, Fetterman had a stroke, so
we're going to vote for the completely clueless,
unqualified hypocrite Mehmet Oz. That doesn't make
any sense either. And the right very in a very
contrived way talking about this in the context
of Fetterman. But yet they don't even mention
that Herschel Walker, the Republican candidate
in Georgia, cannot speak, cannot think, lies
endlessly, and you can't tell if he's disoriented
or deliberately lying or what. They are total
hypocrites. And if you are going to raise these
questions about Fetterman now, where have you
been for a year on Herschel Walker, who is an
embarrassment to the mere concept of a candidacy?
Let's talk a little bit about Herschel Walker next